hey really quick our sponsor Babel is
giving you 25% off when you use the link
under this video I recently went to
Italy I knew a very little Italian a
month ago but after spending just a few
weeks using the Babel language learning
app before the trip I was able to
confidently have conversations in
Italian while I was over there the
lessons were quick and easy I did it all
on my phone you don't waste time
learning things that aren't relevant and
you actually remember what you learn I'm
going to stick with it you should check
it out too and you'll get 25% off when
you use the link underneath this video
yesterday I reported to you that the
Donald Trump campaign did some internal
polling in a number of key battleground
states and that Donald Trump currently
according to his own campaigns internal
polls is losing some major important
2016 battleground states to most if not
all likely Democratic challengers in
hypothetical one-on-one matchups Trump's
reaction as I told you yesterday was
Barry the polls say were doing great
period now unfortunately at the same
time that Donald Trump's campaign was
doing internal polling in a lot of these
battleground states
other regular pollsters were also doing
polls in those battleground states and
the public polls say the exact same
thing Donald Trump is not doing
particularly well right now in
one-on-one matchups in a number of key
states including Wisconsin and Michigan
and Pennsylvania and others now Donald
Trump has been presented with the public
polls showing that he's currently losing
to every major 2020 Democratic candidate
in these hypothetical 2020 matchups and
Trump has absolutely lost it and is now
claiming that the polls are totally fake
Donald Trump tweeting in a to tweet
tweet storm quote the fake news has
never been more dishonest than it is
today thank goodness we can fight back
on social media their new weapon of
choice is fake polling capital F in fake
capital P in polling sometimes referred
to as suppression polls they suppress
the numbers had it in 2016 but this is
worse the
fake corrupt news media said they had a
leak into polling done by my campaign
which by the way and despite the phony
and never-ending witch-hunt are the best
numbers we have ever had lie lie lie I
mean this is all lies they reported
capital F fake numbers and then that
they made up and don't even exist all
caps we will win again now there are
people on the Left who actually agree
with Trump that the polls are totally
fake and they email me daily and they
tell me Joe Biden's not really winning
the Democratic primary bernie is
actually ahead of Biden or Tulsi is
actually polling 10% not 1% you can't
believe anything that's there now I've
already talked about what is and isn't
accurate about polling but the polls are
not fake okay if your evidence is we
know twenty twenty polls are fake
because twenty eighteen polls were
totally wrong and fake and 2016 polls
were totally wrong and fake well the
2016 national polls were correct they
had Hillary winning by two or three
points nationally and she did of course
she lost the electoral college
ultimately because of these 77,000 votes
in three states that were within the
margin of error but the national polls
were right in 2016 the national polls
were basically right in 2018 as well in
terms of what would happen in the Senate
with Democrats and Republicans and what
would happen in the house with Democrats
and Republicans so I don't know what
that contingent of the left is referring
to I don't know what Trump is referring
to because what is now publicly being
said in these polls is the exact same
thing that Donald Trump's own internal
polls of these battleground states are
saying and specifically Donald Trump I'm
guessing is referring to a new
Quinnipiac poll from this week where
Donald Trump is losing to every leading
2020 Democrat let's put the results up
on the screen Trump versus Biden Biden
53 Trump 40 Sanders 51 Trump 42 that's
plus 9 for Bernie Kamala Harris 49 Trump
41 that's plus 8 for Kamala Warren 49 to
42 over Trump that's plus 7 Budaj edge
and Cory Booker both 47 to 42 plus 5
over Donald Trump so normal caveats here
number one
is it likely that Donald Trump will end
up with only 40 or 41 percent of the
vote in the 2020 election no Donald
Trump is going to get more unless
there's a serious third party challenger
Trump's going to get more than 40 or 41
percent there are some undecideds in
those numbers that are ultimately going
to vote most likely for either Trump or
the Democratic challenger there hasn't
been is it likely Trump will lose the
popular vote by 7 8 9 10 13 even as is
being shown in the Quinnipiac poll
absolutely not there has not been a
popular vote margin of 10 or greater in
a presidential election since Ronald
Reagan 35 years ago and it would be very
unlikely to happen in 2020 but the main
takeaway here the point is Trump's not
doing well right now 17 months from the
election in a number of battleground
states and nationally against
hypothetical Democratic presidential
nominees who we don't even actually know
who is going to be the nominee yet
there's even a poll this is amazing
there's a poll showing Trump down to Joe
Biden in Texas by four points which is
very close to Trump's net favorability
in Texas which is minus three meaning
three percentage points more see Trump
unfavorably in Texas and then favoring
favorably but I want to every time we do
polling stuff I'm gonna go back to this
because it's so important and I
apologize the people who say I've said
this enough I can't possibly say it
enough I want to caution everyone to be
very careful here we actually want Trump
to think that he's winning because if
Donald Trump really thinks the polls are
fake maybe he really does believe that
he's currently winning in these
head-to-head matchups that's what we
want because a Trump who thinks he's
winning and that he has it in the bag
hopefully won't actually go out in
campaign and he'll hang around the White
House and he'll play golf and he'll send
weird tweets out and that will make it
more likely that he ultimately will lose
in 2020 it's really important to
understand that we want to on the one
hand not take for granted no matter what
the polls say you as an individual voter
should operate under the belief
that your vote could swing the election
to or away from Trump in your state okay
and if you take that approach what you
would do on Election Day or as soon as
early voting starts in your state is you
would go and you would vote so no matter
what the polls say assume operate under
the guise that your vote could make the
difference that's number one number two
when it comes to what Trump thinks about
polls the better Trump thinks he's doing
the less he's going to campaign the less
seriously he's going to take the
possibility that he gets defeated in
2020 and we have to remember
systemically we are at a disadvantage
gerrymandering favors Republicans number
one number two the urban-rural divide
favors Republicans in conjunction with
the electoral college number three when
we consider all of the different
possible types of interference that
Donald Trump said to George
Stephanopoulos yesterday he would
welcome in 2020 in terms of opposition
research or Oppo research as Trump calls
that against potential Democratic
candidates there's a whole bunch of
stuff systemically stacked against us
the voter suppression tactics that they
will continue to employ so the better
Trump thinks he's doing the less likely
it is he will take action that might
actually help him in 2020 and that's
something we shouldn't forget either
make sure you're following the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show follow me while you're there at
David Pakman lots of great
behind-the-scenes pictures from my trip
to Los Angeles last week and a lot of
other great stuff we will take a quick
break and be back right after this